all right i'm laura ingram this is the
ingram angle from washington tonight
the post-americans that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
the nine-hour raid at mar-a-lago the
perpetual expansion of the surveillance
state on bogus grounds the long pandemic
lockdowns that harm children close
businesses and churches even
the endless re-upping of emergency
coveted powers
the destruction of historical markers
and statues the use of big tech as proxy
censors for the current regime
all of this all of it points to one ugly
inescapable conclusion
our government is being run by a cadre
of powerful post-american forces
our current political leadership acts as
though
our constitution and the freedoms
protected by that constitution are no
longer valid
there'll always be a reason for them to
ignore our constitution these days like
systemic racism they'll talk climate
change or another covid variant maybe
gun violence january 6th
and they won't explicitly say it at
least not yet but
they don't want us to live under a
constitution
that leaves the primary decision making
to the people of the 50 states
nor that would they want the designation
american citizen to really have any
special meaning at all for any of us
so we'll retain any rights or privileges
for being american citizens no
because if they believed in the sanctity
of u.s citizenship
they would enforce the border they
wouldn't leave it open for millions to
enter and just stay here
but if the constitution isn't what
protects america what will
we're going to defend the rules-based
international order
that protects us all one of our defining
missions is to strengthen the
international rules-based order our
shared determination to defend the
rules-based international order this is
about the future of the liberal world
order and we have to stand firm
of course there's no such thing as the
liberal or rules-based international
order they're all
flapping their gums about because as we
saw during covid
when you know what hits the fan well
countries do what's in their own
self-interest remember when germany
banned the export of medical equipment
during covet i remember that
so so much for the rules-based
international order
and of course china russia they're never
going to agree to this nonsense anyway
or or if they did agree
to some set of rules
they just
say okay yeah we agree then we'd go on
and cheat
because this is how the real world works
whether we're talking climate change or
global internet taxation or trade the
path that the post-americans want to
take us down it's going to ensure that
we have less freedom
less prosperity
and less independence for all americans
now the real power in this soros kind of
approved style fantasyland will belong
to things like the who the un the eu
commission on human rights the world
economic forum
and the real decisions will be left to
nameless faceless committees and
commissions
and then those decisions will be carried
out by the lackeys that operate here
people like mark milley anthony fauci
merrick garland
and of course these post-americans
have the benefit of an entire academic
system that advances this narrative from
pretty much kindergarten on up
and since we have almost no true
independent press corps left in america
they're not going to investigate or
expose any of this
instead they either cheer or play
defense for the regime
so they're not going to inquire as to
why 87 000 new irs agents
that why they're needed in america right
now
instead they just ooh and ah about
biden's great week
this has been a i mean joe biden's been
on a hell of a run he has gotten a lot
done i mean an incredible amount done
what joe biden has done demonstrated
competency they can run on a contrast
message of competency and we get stuff
done versus crazy really caps off a
pretty stunning two years for
president joe biden's first two years in
office biden has had a long list of
legislative wins during his first two
years in office
they pretend to care about norms and
procedures
and they warned about how trump's
behavior led americans to question our
entire democratic system it's always
teetering on the edge
yet they call it conspiratorial when
anyone questions the propriety
of a nine-hour raid of the home of
biden's possible 2024 opponent
the justice department is returning to
its historical position as a law
enforcement agency above politics trying
to do the right thing mayor carlin
garland is the most careful judicious to
a fault some would say
uh you know attorney general in this
case to watch the base
call for
um protests or or chaos or dissent or
disrespect for the fbi is a new horror
and a new low i think their reaction
last 24 hours has been disgusting
well but the disgusting truth is that
they don't really believe that trump
should be protected by the rights
enumerated in this constitution
because they have one set of standards
and rules for hillary clinton and hunter
biden
and then they have another set of rules
for trump and any of his supporters or
people who work for him
and this is why if you really press them
these elitist snobs would prefer that
americans were forced to live under
policies made in consultation with the
eu and other countries
if they had their druthers they'd have a
central committee maybe it would be in
brussels or helsinki and that would
determine how much beef you should eat
how much ac you should be allowed to use
how far you should be allowed to drive
and in what kind of car
even the language that you're allowed to
use or opinions you're allowed to
express online or
whether you should be able to own a
firearm of any kind
and of course they always use clever
language don't they about their mission
and their goals
reinventing democracy to fit
the challenges of the 21st century
may sound like a tall order
but this is the mission of our
generation populism is trying to to
destroy the democratic institutions
as courts and rule of law but also the
free press and so on if we want to have
democracy it means dealing with climate
change first of all
most an elected office won't be so
brazen as to say what they really
believe
that it's time to leave behind our old
ideas of these quaint all
notions of productivity and merit of the
american dream leave that all behind
because now it's about lowering your
expectations
and they're going to use orwellian
language to make this transition as they
like to call it seem wonderful and even
noble
there's no doubt
we expect growth to be slower lasted
than last year
but that's consistent with the
transition to a stable steady growth we
are in a transition we had this strong
economic growth a transition into stable
and steady growth transitioning to more
steady sustainable growth
defining question of the next few years
will be the following
will america remain an independent
country and which the federal government
is subject to and constrained by the
traditional restrictions of our
constitution
or will we basically become second-class
subjects in a global order where the key
decisions are made by people that no
american ever voted for
when you think about it after 13 long
years
our populist movement has finally begun
to unify most republicans behind the
traditions of american independence and
our constitutional republic
but meanwhile the democrats the never
trumpers they've kind of formed their
own alliance in support of this liberal
international order
we have our voters and we have our
enthusiasm and we have policies that
actually have worked for over 200 years
they have their bureaucrats their big
tech plutocrats and their media
operatics
along with policies that are leaving us
poorer and weaker
many americans i think were naive to
think that the left-wing extremists
would settle down when statues of robert
e lee were taken down and with trump out
of office they thought that things would
return to normal the normal course of
things
but the angle warned you
that all that was just the beginning and
that their plans go far beyond
sabotaging trump in 2024
this has always been about sabotaging an
entire nation
our way of life
so will the post americans win
well that's up to you
and how hard you work between now and
2024
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else